welcome to this new video in the series
chess Giants yeah I had a recently I had
a game Graham Tigran Petrosian was the
victim of a brutal attack by bent Larsen
so I am figured I should show a win of
petrosian's um and this is a very
untypical game for Petrosian he is very
famous for his son great positional
grinds those kind of long long-winded
long games where he step-by-step takes
away all kinds of play from the opponent
and finally wins it was a very fine
prophylactic player and he really had
clear-cut attacking games but sometimes
it it was really also happening in his
chest so this is one of the games I
actually managed to yeah to win quickly
I'm telling you that much in case if you
don't know the game his opponent here is
a ludic pac-man grandmaster originally
from Czechoslovakia he however left the
country after he had problems with them
with the the left-wing regime that he
was protesting against it in the spring
the Prague Spring is this also an
English ending and known in English as
with this term yeah well he left him a
Slovakia and he went to Germany I think
in the early 70s if I'm not mistaken and
played for Germany for a couple of years
yeah this game was spent in 1961 in the
beautiful city of place or town of blade
near the league blade here want a nice
destination to visit on your holidays go
to blade and Slovenia yeah let's look at
the game and we have a sort of Kings
Indian attack by Petrosian he played
that sometimes not too often but it was
part of
opening repertoire so white is just
doing his four moves up to castling and
he pretty much says okay you can do
whatever you want I'm going to set up
something with d3 and d4 yeah here
Parkman also could have opted for d5 set
up like this or go for a direct approach
with E 5 he decided to play the movie 6
which is perfectly okay of course he 497
now rook e1 by a Trojan yeah the black
setup is very common it happens in the
English opening in the close Sicilian
and of course this opening resembles the
close Sicilian ìbut White has the knight
on f3 which is not ideal sometimes and
the clothes to see in you often have to
ff4 plate he however you don't have
knight on c3 which is quite nice
sometimes as you can play with c3 yeah
black here has a choice he can play with
d5 again very popular nowadays the most
popular move nowadays is a 5 in fact it
looks a bit strange because you move the
e pawn twice but it does make some sense
black is clamping down on d4 and in this
kind of structure the rook is sometimes
not ideally place only one as you might
want to prepare her for at some point
yeah black here is definitely ok even
with this type of tempo loss but not
played castles this is not very popular
among stronger players nowadays but it
seems in fact playable it's a bit bit
different than a 5 because it allows
white to play this following move this
looks attractive I think because it yeah
sort of sets up this advanced pawn that
is blocking this Bishop so the bishop
only sin is not that great and black I
think needs to yeah immediately make
sure that this pawn is going away you
cannot tolerate this this pawn for a
very long time
time if white gets enough time here he
might play something like this this
Bishop h6 trade off this bishop and play
on the kingside note that the dark
squares are already yeah the there is a
tendency that the dark squares might
become weak played d6 he wanted to as
men should get rid of the pawn
I think this is okay 92 and Queen c7
yeah the Queen was somewhat
unfortunately placed him for 94 Nazi for
things like that the children now plays
an interesting move Knight to b3 this is
not a very M a very typical place for
for this piece in this type of structure
normally you would expect it to go to c4
but Knight B 3 has a very direct at the
end just take the pawn sometimes the
simple ideas are also quite interesting
yeah
it is however the case that if black
plays precisely now he still is okay
well Padma now needed to do was to
defend with b6 which looks pretty normal
yeah you cover your attack pawn but it's
of course a little bit of the move that
you should be should be cautious with s
you weaken the long diagonal very much
Bishop f4 very logical move and now we
see the long diagonal problem a 5 is
punished very directive wide wins a pawn
it has an excellent position on top I
mean black will probably lose much more
material as you have a hard time to do
something against knight c6 and
everything looks terrible so b6 Bishop
a4 you cannot go a 5 so the Queen must
move in the original booyah tone for
this event I actually have this
information here from chess space they
had Queen b7 as the move after which
Knight e5 is just very nice for white
yeah we
set up this this pin and frankly
speaking I don't really know why Queen
d7 was suggested because it looks really
awful um however if black just plays
Queen d8 which is yeah it looks a bit
like one move sorry black plate one
Queen move another Queen move another
Queen move again yes that's true but
what it's not about what we did before
but what it's on the board and if the
position on the board is okay it does
not matter that we have moved the Queen
three times in fact here black seems to
be okay he has a pretty decent control
it's still over d4 and after let's say
95 we should be 7 there is nothing
particularly bad happening to black or
alternatively deform but I can take what
takes or the other one yeah you can also
take with this maybe this is better
controlling e5 we should be 7 and then
we continue from here um here white does
not have anything special he has a an
okay position yeah but why does not
really have any a big advantage or
something like that
yeah Backman Oh ever played the move
Knight to g4 yeah I understand that b6
maybe it does not seem did not seem very
attractive to him but unjustifiably so
it seems but 94 really is worse after
that black is already in serious serious
trouble Bishop f4 very simple reply
developing this piece and what black
really now must do something about the
Queen it seems that after the next month
that one is already in in very very very
big trouble here check this was still
possible it is not very nice but
something like the
still seems to be playable for like
three look at this position white
definitely enjoys pressure here on the
Queen side we have this night with might
can come into the action not immediately
I'm the queen is covering some novel
squares but something like that is
definitely better for whitey I note that
the pawn on d5 is also blocking the
bishop here so better for white but
black is still yeah hang on and can then
defend Backman played the Queen to b6
and moving the Queen again and now after
Knight e5 we see the big problem with
this move white is intending to play
Knight C form with a tempo and possibly
also invading on d6 this whole setup
with a 6 C v g6 yeah it really leaves
lots of dark-squared weaknesses behind d
6f 6 h 6 and this is why it needs to be
handled with caution
now black really really really really
needed to take him it looks very very
ugly but you probably need to do that
Bishop takes and now f6 this was still a
position that black can try to defend ya
note that if white goes here after
something like a 5 Bishop h6 whoop t8y
does not have anything right here he has
two bishops true but black also has got
a good knight on the form and a good
central position the bishop blacking on
the king's heart is not such a big deal
you're not going to get made it here
White has no attacking pieces so
probably we should play like like that
as watch takes and takes and now the
move c3 this is some probably the best
continuation that that white white has
some as its disposal let's say yeah
after the capture y dispatch we
have this these pawns can advance six
this week this is quite clearly better
for white so probably Knight f5 keeping
this this point for the moment and then
white will take and yeah we definitely
can assess that white has a small
advantage yeah after this for example
and yeah white just enjoys in this
excellent bishop and there's somewhat
better but it needed to be played that
man took on b3 and now white handed has
strong intermediate moves he first
played 94 attacking the Queen yeah black
queen mmm went to Anne to b5 yeah we can
briefly look at the alternative queen d8
after Queen d8 8 xb3
the big problem is that the c5 pawn is
under it's becoming a target for white
white has ideas like Bishop d6 and just
take it or even look a five and just
take it and like has a really hard time
to defend that if we look at for example
here black playing Knight f5 which looks
pretty logical covering T six white
really can play the strong who gave five
and we're just going to take this pawn
without being punished for that if black
is not reacting black has this neat
little trick we should be too after
which white should play the intermediate
move Queen d2 yeah
Knight B to was not possible here gather
group was hanging so oops I'm sorry
about that
mmm
so let's go back to the line because I'm
not yet finished
yeah like has this this way to hang on
for the moment and now clearly - yeah
and now see with a five also being
protected that after a bishop move
forced we will take and this is really a
very nice position for what if we look
at this how is black going to develop
his Queen side b6 mmm
there is this thing hanging there should
be seven less be seven hain so you have
a hard time to move anything on the
Queen side so very nice for white but
this is probably what part one should
have tried would have been hard for him
to survive this but but still okay Queen
b5 was played and no 8xb
we have the same ideas now Bishop d6 is
in the mix and here especially rook a5
winning the spawn directly this is also
the reason why Batman now played the
very ugly loopy move on a5 yeah very
ugly but a5 was just winning this pawn
so he's keeping him at least his
material somehow went together that you
know does not want to lose it quickly
yeah this should be six strong move
attacking the knight and black went
Bishop f6 it seems that rook e8 was a
little bit tougher but white enjoys a
very good position on nevertheless for
example if we if we consider a move like
Bishop c7 here we see that a five is
hanging three times now I was a tech
three times and there is 96 like well
not black will not save this probably
but he can hang on after Bishop f6
Petrosian played Queen f3 yeah and now
we see that there are liabilities yeah
black really has no other sensible move
than King g7 yeah and after King g7 here
Petrossian had a very
strong means that he did not play and
I'm not going to show it to you because
I want to show you how the game finished
first he played the move rook to e4 and
this move has a very very clear idea
that in fact black cannot really prevent
in a way he played rook to eight and now
white was able to to finish this game
very nicely if you don't know it you can
try to work out the lines for yourself
and treat this as a little puzzle going
to be silent for a couple of seconds
that you can pause it if you want okay
yeah
Petrosian now have the very nice move
Queen takes chat six check hi Queen
sacrifice King takes check you should be
fiber check King g5
yeah if black goes to f5 check check
checkmate head will end like that so
King here and now the the quickest way
to win was played back the chosen Bishop
g7 very nice and this is the real big
point of it by yeah if you want
fianchetto the bishop you on g7 white
cuts off those important squares note
that dark squares the weakened the
weakened color complex and after Bishop
g7 pokémon resigned yes black is mated
now he cannot prevent checkmates we can
look at some lines let's say black ties
if I've to defend then White has aged
King age five
jack takes lead you form
checkmate 93 or if you interpose or
something handmade this made very nice
yeah that's five what else is there
let's say age five we go check here here
checkmate or f5 sorry or f5 we go check
checkmate with this made so very very
nice black cannot avoid checkmate now
after Bishop g7 and Batman has mentioned
I think resigned if we now go back to
this position it is really funny that
already here Petrosian could have played
this winning combination it is even
possible without the rook being only
four so Queen f6 sort of one as well
King takes Jack if I check King g5 and
Bishop g7 it's the same point the same
idea
yeah black already cannot save this King
it's really remarkable so let's say for
instance he moves his room then f4 check
King g4 yeah this is checkmate very
quick to here check
checkmate very very nice I mean this is
a very nice coordination of pieces
especially beautiful as the bishop on g7
yeah what what is there for black it
seems that the the toughest way to
defend is at least in terms of moves
count is Queen c6h looks kinda
ridiculous
yeah other things they don't help with
black let's say moves the knight check
check checkmate not a maid yeah there
are so many hidden heist checkmates yep
yeah Queen c6 is there the longest the
move that ya hangs on the longest but of
course it still wins and very nicely
with the crying's 95 okay black now can
can do this
desperado sec check and play something
let's say here we go x4 King h5 and now
the point in age 3 yeah of course white
can take the rook and win with a look up
but h3 is the made with g4 and checkmate
yeah for example if black plays
something like that
check Oh checkmate this made check
checkmate
or this made yeah and yeah what else is
there let's say here tonight a3 check
check
he had 5 rupees I King G for checkmate
wait yeah this was even even quicker and
theoretically speaking also yeah better
this this earlier sacrifice because
after rookie for black could have played
something like that giving up the
exchange and avoid the immediate
checkmate combination but of course this
is just a theoretical possibility as 95
as useless white legs and wins yeah so
we have an interesting case where this
kind of idea was even working one move
earlier and remarkably working because
you would think that this rupee for
something that you you need to to to
have it working but why he could have
taken one move earlier it is very
beautiful this way yeah to to win after
about 20 moves with a knight f3 g3 type
of opening it's not happening very much
and yeah do it doing it with a king
hunters is really remarkable
so a very nice wind of course here for
them the later world champion 61 I'm not
quite sure about the exact date yet we
had I'm just thinking was it town
already and 61 could could beat all
about winning camera not totally sure
about those 1960-61 this kind of this
period of time
Petrosian this became world champion in
1963 so about two years after this game
was played yeah I hope you enjoyed list
this little gem it's a very well known
game but if you like chess I think it
does not really matter if you see a game
a second time or third time because it's
still beautiful I mean if you think
about it you probably have listened to
your favorite records more than once so
it does not really hurt you to see a
very very nice game more than once okay
I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching